[拍手]
が可動だけですこの同じとに悪いところを直しても
聞いたらなんか何で子供のがわかったこという
もう今回わけじゃないでしょうか
をターンしたがあれはれる
溺愛じゃないですか
と話しとって麻疹に先程お坊さんがっ
いてたように
が豊富でいろんなことを知っているか
元の会にとって指揮する側です
の気持ち
9たちにしかわからない
皆さん多分指摘されることがこの先生に
家で親ぎっ
ありがとうたくなると思います
そういう時
ナンデ勘が滞在時
もそれを実際にいっぱいん
それを着替えたりすることはありません
だから親の方素敵それがわー
パーシーことを言ってるのに
どうしてなぜか人間関係が悪くなります
子供にしたいと思っ
成功なってしまってい
それの映画彼
レオ
を結局別として
伝えてしまう
らいさんに伝えてしまう直接使わないから
改善することをない
将来
僕たちがあ
社会予定
歯医者と薬とか言え
たとえ内でを有し変える場合近い立場になったとき
こういうことを忘れてしまうと3
そうあの指摘して欲しくないのかそうないだけないって思ったこと
今日だけは自分は0人くらいとして記載がゼロまで少し
を伝える者はなるん
エア rg 1いいと思っ
皆さんもぜひ自分などを指摘された
考えながら言った
テーマに国は子ども now
そのため同じような原因があると思うんですが使えたら
いやじゃあするような大全集
a
絶対舞雪くれい
あれからデザイン思ってしまいますよね
のやらなきゃいけないことがあるのに
連絡歳からさ持ってしまう
バイロン子供の人の特徴はしてあると思います
1つは経験やどうでしょうか
line 年齢関係なくこういう特徴を出しとっています
これこれ応援特徴を持った明日に真面目に指摘しても
改善したがるって事は天にあります
どうすればあたを食べずにして規制指摘できるようになるべき
それを考え少し声をご覧下さいん
[音楽]
聞いちゃあ放送されていただいた
うわぁ
昔このもの時に小学生の時
なんかいいなと思います
もうライザー部に入ったら
こういうふうに
憧れの示す票で演じられるじゃないが
この cm ではー
別に直接アラクネ裏から大作に帰りなさい
比べ
来賊に通うとお一人様2
理想の体が手にできるよう
そういうことを言っています
間接的に自分来札に入ることをこのサービスを受けることでメインとすることを言っ
てるだけ
自分を抑えてやってみたいこの人みたいに真似してみたいって思えるんです
うわぁ方法で指摘した方がいいなぁ
薬や場所ツアーは全市的に言うと
第言う等
ありがとうございます
雑談する中でありません
強いよねー
を回避始まる10分マンや絶対来てて論点整理してくれたり持ち上げてくれたりしてて
すごい尊敬しているんだ
それ言われたら
ああこういう人が尊敬されるのかこういう人がいいと思われるとかえら分かります
やら自分をその人のことまでしたくないんです
えんちゃんまどろっこしいですかね
確かに
私の方すごい日がございます
使って一瞬で解説も交えさせる
どちらも片面
防衛的だと思います
でも皆さんも向かずとかで経験があると思うんですけど
線スコーンの先生がいる強い人がいるそういう時は
みんな一生懸命練習するのに
際人がいないになるいなくなった時その人がいない a 4の時はみんなダウン
サボってしまう
なんか分かりますよねん
それと同じように好意して話し方をするといなくなったときに
基の60万根本的な改善につながらないんじゃないか
これまで僕ら感じ方を説明し
皆さんが多かったでしょうか
同じだなって思う人
考え方が似てるなって思ってもいいと思い
逆に考え方が全然違うなって思います
感じ方は本当に慕われるわけです
によってどうしてきたじゃないか
全然違うと思います
だから相手の
過去代表格好のことがいい
らせるように出席するとき
運動の関係が悪くならないように相手に通してきた星梨花は聞いたり相手に通してきさ
れたいけど
何か伝えたいすることで
環境を悪くしないようにしてい
できるように怒られてみてください静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]